[Aplausos]
pensem numa oportunidade que vocês
tiveram e conseguiram alcançar agora
pensa em como seria se vocês não
tivessem tido acesso à internet
a falta do acesso à internet traz
conseqüências sociais traz consequências
no acesso ao conhecimento
limitar o acesso ao conhecimento é
limitar o acesso a dados ou limitar o
acesso à informação limitar o acesso à
aprendizagem
a própria falta de acesso à internet já
é uma consequência social e não estou
falando simplesmente de uma internet
ilimitado a falta de um acesso que meu
pacote de dados
acabou eu preciso pagar um extra
estou falando do acesso à internet como
instrumento de transformação instrumento
de mudança ou entendemos que a gente tá
no momento da história um momento
inédito na história que o acesso à
internet para todos uma capacidade de
diminuir as diferenças sociais e as
desigualdades ou a gente vai perder essa
oportunidade
nesse exato momento em que a gente está
aqui nesses 15 minutos duas mil pessoas
estão acessando em algum ponto do acessa
são paulo que é um programa de acesso
gratuito à população
duas mil pessoas estão acessando a
internet nesse exato momento nos mais de
800 postos espalhados no estado e porque
estão lá achando naquele computador de
mesa que a gente acha que já ninguém usa
mais usando aqueles equipamentos com a
ajuda de monitores treinados aquela
conexão ensinar porque se eles não
tivessem acessando desse lugar
eles não teriam acesso em nenhum lugar
eu estou nessa área da inclusão digital
desde a época que internet era chamada
de projeto das infovias em 99
eu tinha uma carreira numa multinacional
entre como trinitá com uma carreira
super ascendente mas já vinha me
incomodando com algumas questões mais
amplas e ao mesmo tempo eu vinha com
essa chegada da internet era muito
interessante começou a surgir a tal da
inteligência coletiva e resumidamente a
inteligência coletiva pra mim é a
essência da inteligência coletiva é
ninguém sabe tudo mas todo mundo sabe
alguma coisa e aí essas idéias começaram
a me preocupar e eu pedi um sabático fui
para nova york e lá eu fiz tudo quanto é
coisa do digital cinema digital educação
digital e comércio digital e nas minhas
andanças por lá um livro muito
importante apareceu assim na minha mãe
chamava manifesto com o trem traduzido é
o manifesto da cultura digital que
basicamente dizer essa potência da rede
essa potência de estar conectado do
acesso à informação a dar conhecimento e
as pessoas internet mas que a tecnologia
internet são as pessoas e aí já na época
e tinha umas umas estações uma escada de
acesso à internet
e eu lembro que eu freqüentava essas
casas e um dia eu estava andando lá e
pensei nossa isso aqui revolucionar a
internet vai realmente revolucionar a
forma da gente aprender a forma da gente
conhecer as coisas à forma antiga nos
relacionar com as oportunidades mas
peraí para quem que vai ser isso tudo
mais uma vez essa oportunidade não só
para os que já têm as mesmas
oportunidades
porque isso não vai conseguir chegar pra
todo mundo de uma vez essa coisa que um
site assim foi nossa mas isso não vai
chegar pra todo mundo
então eu quero me dedicar para que isso
chegue para todo mundo
assim pra mim é claro
voltei a cabeleira nova york fazendo um
projeto com o próprio pr evitá-la de
inteligência coletiva vim para são paulo
e comecei a bater na porta de algumas
instituições poucas que já que estamos
começando a falar sobre isso
foi quando eu bati na porta do
laboratório na usp chamado escola do
futuro da uso esse laboratório
ele estuda justamente é o impacto da
internet e das tecnologias na educação e
na comunicação
não cheguei a bater à porta e fui dizer
que encontrei com o coordenador
científico professor fredric litto um
homem visionário ele recebeu e eu de
frente para ele falando que eu tive um
site que não só que isso é ser
revolucionário à internet mas a internet
teria que ser para todos porque se não é
assim a gente aumentar o gap e
tecnologia ao invés de diminuir as
diferenças e ampliar a diferença quando
ele olhou pra mim calmo e disse depois
de meia hora
drica o que você precisa fazer chama-se
inclusão digital e aí eu vou nós tem o
nome assim o que eu queria fazer
e foi isso eu quero trabalhar com isso
desde essa conversa até hoje os mais de
16 anos foi o que eu fiz naquele
programa acessa são paulo que eu que a
gente também sou negra a pouco eu
comecei não existe o programa hoje o
programa tem seus 16 anos mais de 3
milhões de pessoas acessam nos mais de
800 postos e uma das das dos princípios
que norteiam nosso projeto chama ética
hacker que são princípios que nortearam
inclusive
a própria o desenvolvimento da internet
rápida porque os hackers que
desenvolviam a programação mas no fundo
não é só um filho é uma filosofia de
vida é um modo de vida compartilhamento
abertura de centralização livre acesso
aos computadores e à internet e à
informação e melhoria do mundo aqui é só
para a gente entender a situação um ser
menos aqui não tem ou seja a gente está
basicamente no brasil isso a nível
brasil 66 quando a gente vai ver
população urbana e rural aí a coisa se
agrava no rural a gente tem 68% que não
têm acesso
quando a gente vai olhar por região a
que eles estavam no sudeste é a que mais
tem acesso 60% vai caindo até o norte 35
por cento só tem acesso a todo mundo
não é todo mundo agora aqui que a gente
vai ver a grande polarização por classe
social a classe a 98% esses dois por
cento praticamente é por não querer pôr
não é normalmente geracional é puro
você é mais velho classe b 82% classe c
4814 em termos de estou falando que
classe a b praticamente 29 milhões de
pessoas classe 62 8 milhões classe de 49
milhões 49 milhões que não 86% diz que
não tem acesso não é uma escolha a não
vou não tem não tem oportunidade pobres
informação tendem ser cada vez mais
pobres e ricos e informação tendem a ser
cada vez mais ricos
a capacidade de uma pessoa tem de
receber processar e adquirir
conhecimento depende principalmente de
três fatores a seu conhecimento anterior
as redes sociais que participa eo nível
de exposição
os comunicação eu já via internet
instalado nos mais diferentes lugares
estação do metrô posto de saúde
assentamento rural escola sempre sempre
me emociona como pode mudar com o
impacto na vida de cada pessoa e no
entorno
aí eu aprendi a mexer um pouquinho no
facebook zap e agora as pessoas
amanhã a hora que eu for para a
biblioteca e eu te levo ok me fala que
eu vou querer o quanto ela está ok
aí pode trazer umas bolachinhas um pão
depois falou aí eu no outro dia eu vim
pra cá para o curso e trouxe para ela
algumas diferenças
nossa muita diferença porque agora não
se saiba o sol quente eu faço desde
chovendo ou não a pessoa usa eu tenho
mais ou menos 70 e 80 primeiros então
pra mim foi muito bom
é muito bacana né
eu me emociono também mas aqui mas ainda
falta ainda falta muita coisa e eu
queria que vocês saírem daqui
mobilizados com essa causa essa é uma
causa muito importante oferecer
oportunidade de acesso à informação
acesso ao conhecimento acesso estar em
rede é fundamental nesse momento natal
da sociedade da informação sociedade em
rede
a gente tem que pressionar a gente tem
que pressionar os órgãos responsáveis o
governo empresa para que seja oferecida
banda larga de qualidade para todos
porque no final cada um aqui e até ao
longo do dia ea gente fica com essa
clareza cada um aqui pode fazer a
diferença num espaço que está na sala de
aula o seu bairro na sua casa é como se
fossem pequenas histórias
a gente tem muitas pequenas histórias
não é a grande história da internet a
grande história da inteligência coletiva
são milhares de pequenas histórias
pequenas versões subversões somos
milhares de subversivos
essa potência de ação só vai fazer
sentido para valer se ela tiver ao
alcance de todos
a gente não fizer da tecnologia que pode
ser uma grande diminuidor das
desigualdades a gente tem que fazer que
ela diminua não que amplie e de novo o
problema do acesso à internet banda
larga não é dispositivo de acesso
o problema crítico é banda larga
um pouco afastado o que quero é o casal
então o sinal de internet até hoje é
ruim
aí eu vim o cadastro inscrição para a
fatec de são sebastião que investir na
escola pública de ensino gratuito
nisso eu me inscrevi tudo pela sé são
paulo me inscrevi acompanhei data
horário e aí eu lembro do dia que eu fui
verificar se tinha passado na faculdade
de cinco mil quadrados moto aí a gente
for lá
aí eu fui usar entrei liberei o acesso
mas depois que eu eu vi aí eu entrei
direto no site
aí eu fui lista de classificados quando
vi meu nome eu não sabia fazer chorar ao
ew contemplou quadrado ficou feliz
aí eu até aceito um monitor no caso do
benefício
a empregada aí foi só isso mesmo mas
também não diz isso porque pra casa
correndo contei para minha mãe e minha
mãe ela fez o papel de divulgação a ela
se encontra no bairro todas ele foi uma
mudança a gente porque minha família não
tinha perspectiva de que alguém ia fazer
uma faculdade uma coisa eu o agradeço
muito o social aqui e também a questão
de ir pelo acesso à internet
legal